counting down in five four three two one
what's up you [ __ ] sexy [ __ ] we
got a special ass damn guests here [ __ ]
mouth special in the sense that this guy
has the the luckiest luck of everything
you know I got a I got a make sure that
I be careful about my legs because last
time I was recording this [ __ ] I was
more some short shorts all you saw was
dick and balls really yeah yeah like
straight up it was like the whole
imprint of my dick in my testicles so I
had to make a note to zoom out cuz it
was too tight
oh damn you should just let it hang bro
I would have but it's extra tiny so
people can get the literal inference of
the size of it okay I didn't like that
so what you doing man I'm good I'm good
I just I just got a facial and real men
get facials [ __ ] real man [ __ ] you know
what's funny is I realize I'm turning
more and more into like an Instagram
model every day I push the fashion over
I pushed happy tea and now it's like I'm
doing facials in exchange for like story
all you need is tummy tea bro and then
you're done
you know what I was thinking I was
thinking that maybe cuz like you you
notice the flat tummy tea [ __ ] kind of
disappeared yeah and now you see happy
tea everywhere yeah so I feel like
because of the stigma that kind of came
with the flat tummy teas cuz a lot of
people were talking [ __ ] and a lot of
people were like saying it's actually
not healthy and this and this and that I
think it's a rebrand for them I think
that company because I don't know this
is y'all just me too speculating right
but I feel like for them it was like we
gotta find something else to get into
and then so they kind of took their
money like what else can we do found the
CBD [ __ ] and rework their brand and now
they're probably you know like they're
doing the exact same thing though right
like paying instagram models to
advertise it but this is like less of
like oh oh this will make you skinny and
just uh oh this actually works it'll
make you sleep it'll relax you
but CBD actually does work that's
something like it works so there's if
they get backlash from that I am they're
pretty much out of loss at this point
yeah I know I've literally received like
no backlash from from the happy tea [ __ ]
you know yeah I mean for me to like I've
you know you know we talked about this
we're not really like we doesn't really
work with us very well right right like
when I tried when I did edibles that
[ __ ] was he was actually witness to me
experiencing my first edible which was
recently yo so we were shooting the sin
foods and Knott's Berry Farm yeah and
because I knew that I had to be
well-rested for the shoot it was gonna
be a hot day we were gonna be at Knott's
Berry we're gonna walk around a lot I
was like well [ __ ] it I'm an insomniac
the only thing I could really do when
this was before I was trying to lose
weight and workout and I was like I
gotta get some sleep
so my boy Roger who he actually owns a
couple of farms so he has a bunch of
connects to you know just a bunch of
weed [ __ ] decided to give me a brownie
okay now this [ __ ] looked like medically
professional it was sealed it's like a
baby blue like silver bag or whatever
the [ __ ] it is yeah and that he told me
just take a corner piece and it's fine
but what he didn't tell me is that when
you get a brownie you actually don't
know the amount that you're getting
because you don't know how much they
cooked with exactly so you don't know
where the mix is more potent so I just
took a corner piece like you said he
goes you know what just eat that chill
off and see what happens so it made me
fall asleep
mmm check the [ __ ] out though I woke up
high as [ __ ] high as a [ __ ] dude
and I didn't like it because it made me
feel like everything was going in
slow-mo right right yeah see here's the
thing man I
I've never I've never been a weed smoker
yeah I'm saying and and because the
first few times I did it you know people
might say maybe I wasn't doing it right
but I didn't really feel anything it
just made me sleepy right and then the
first time I actually was like oh wow
I'm high or like off off smoking I
remember feeling like I think Rick was
telling me something really important
and he was talking about some serious
[ __ ] like I was at a little house party
was in backyard talking and he was
telling me about something serious and I
just remember looking at him and being
like I don't know what Rick saying to me
but like if he knows that I'm high he's
gonna be pissed yeah giving you is like
real talk like about some serious [ __ ]
and I'm like man yeah crazy and I'm like
holy [ __ ] what is he saying and I was
like I don't like this till this day
Rick doesn't know looks like you know
you [ __ ] dude if I pour my heart
out I was gonna kill myself yeah man
just do it like man that night you were
such a good listener
dude when I was so on the way back
because I was going to Knott's Berry
Farm and I didn't want to drive
obviously cuz I was high yeah so I
[ __ ] called it Oh BRR when I was in
the uber the dude was trying to chat me
up he was like yo bro were you from how
you been on sir hey man I'm nice [ __ ]
but yes I got you so shut the [ __ ] up
turn up the music back up and I just
remember when I got you like cottonmouth
yeah yeah yeah and it was weird because
everything process is so slow and I know
what I'm gonna say and it's gonna be
smartest [ __ ] but it doesn't come out
yeah by the time I develop what I want
to say the times past mm-hmm so
everything so so I hate that cuz I think
I just like being in control especially
in a conversation I want to be involved
right and if I try to speak and people
people say the same thing maybe you're
not doing it right you just gotta let it
take you over I did it a couple times I
still don't like yeah I'm not a fan man
I'm just I'm definitely I like I like
drinking right yeah and even when even
when the nights where I've woken up and
I'm like what the [ __ ] happened last
night what did I do
I still feel like in the moment I'm I'm
coherent you know I know what's going on
it's not like a delayed reaction that
yeah I might be slurring but you feel
like you're in control exactly like when
I'm high I feel I I'm aware that I'm not
in control and I don't like that you
know saying this [ __ ] II said foods
first of all just a little bit of a
background so we're out in Iowa right
it's cold as [ __ ] we just end the night
we already drink a bit and then I'm in
the hotel I get a text message that says
yo me if I don't hit you back up there's
no call so call the cops to me I'm like
you know what the [ __ ] is going on me
being a good friend
I knocked the [ __ ] out I didn't stay
away from I was alright I gotta stay
awake for this dude but we already drank
so I was already tired yeah yeah so I
knocked the [ __ ] out this Patel's me he
meets up Long Beach local rapper
stupid young that is the thing I didn't
think anything was actually gonna happen
yeah but also it was like so here's some
background on this okay so me it's to be
young like we're cool right like you
know he's from Long Beach he has a lot
of buzz right now
I lived in Long Beach so I was like ten
you know I'm saying and I and I you know
I went to school and paramount but
basically long story short we we almost
had beef on accident all right we almost
had beef because um there was a
documentary that came out called bad rap
and it was about oh that's the one with
dumb with dumb aquafina yeah and it was
about Asian rappers okay and um there's
a part where they're interviewing me and
they're asking me about just like you
know being an Asian rapper and and it's
just the perception of Asian people and
I'm talking about how like I know like I
know Asian dudes that will kill you like
I know Asian gangsters that are real and
authentic and I'm saying like I'm
basically saying but it sucks that
America won't accept that so so you
can't talk about that because they won't
believe you hmm and I wasn't trying to
say like you can't talk about that
because it's like you're fake or like
you're lying or you're full of [ __ ] you
know I'm saying I was trying to say like
it sucks that like almost like when you
say you can't be yourself around yeah
yeah your boss you know I'm saying yeah
so but the thing about it is they were
playing that part of me saying that over
clips of stupid young so so I get why he
kind of felt like it was low-key shots
at him like I was kind of like calling
him fake or something you know I'm
saying
oh and he's like a Long Beach [ __ ] do
you like it he's [ __ ] deep like like
like like for real for real yeah you
know I can kill you right so so all of a
sudden one day I'm on IG and I'm getting
an AI and I'm getting comments angry
comments and some and I go and I see
like yo there was like why why you
coming as to be young like that and I
said what are you talking about cuz I
knew who he was right but we had never
communicated so then I went on to stupid
Young's Instagram and he posted a little
picture like a video ahead of him
watching the documentary and he was like
yo Timothy DeLaGhetto got it [ __ ] up
he's [ __ ] up the game right now what
are you saying blah blah and it was a
clip of me saying that part on the
documentary so now I'm in the comments
trying to explain I'm like nah dude it
wasn't like that and some people knew
what I was trying to say but also it was
a lot of people who didn't even watch
the documentary who were just fans us to
be young who were like nah man [ __ ] that
how you gonna disrespect him like that
blah blah
blaah like a lot of like young uns from
Long Beach were on my head Tim the
theater major
are you [ __ ] trying to get killed
what's wrong with you I mean don't get
it twisted I know Beach but yes I do see
a fellow [ __ ]
so um so it was a lot a lot of like
people from Long Beach like oh my head
like upset about it so I'm I'm in the
comments going back and forth with him
he was like look man I'm not about this
like comment [ __ ] he's like he's like
you know talk to me if you talk to me
sorry you know of course i DM him and
I'm like look bro this is what was was
sad blah blah blah and he's like okay
well if that's what you were saying then
here's what I don't understand how come
it was clips of me and I'm like bro I
didn't edit the [ __ ] I'm not in control
of this [ __ ] you know so he kinda he
understood and we squashed it like
literally that that that our
conversation we squashed it was crying
died so look so then I was like alright
cool cool we good let's do something
together he was like yeah and he was
like you know what but you know and he's
like no I respect you too even you know
you've been doing it for the Asians for
a long time blah blah blah and I was
like alright cool a lot of like angry
little Long Beach like gonna kill me
just upset at me he was like oh yeah got
you blah blah and that was that you know
I'm saying well thank [ __ ] god dude
because let me tell you something now
the stupid youngsters like you would Tim
I'm like nah [ __ ] that fool dude talking
[ __ ] about you homie Long Beach
quick-cook so we were in we're in Des
Moines and he randomly he was in Des
Moines sooo you know so he hit me and he
was let and I was like no I saw I texted
him I was like you in Des Moines he was
like yeah pull up like yo that's a vague
ass invite I'm like what's good you got
to show her something he's like not the
homeys house I'm like okay cool
so I'm like this is the first time we've
met you know so I was like okay I like
we're both in Des Moines let me take
this opportunity to like officially like
shake hands and be like yo what's good
blah blah blah like you're good and
brave but also in the back back of my
mind I'm like okay we've never met what
if what if this is a setup
right no for whatever reason right um so
in my head I'm like not do we squash it
is cool
he's just invited me to come drink with
the homies and and I
knew that's what it was gonna be but
also in my head I was like hi man look
this is what I'm gonna be just in case
you don't hear from you tomorrow for
whatever reason but I knew it wasn't
gonna be nothing crazy yeah so I just
ended up going to this house party first
of all my uber took me to the wrong spot
so here's this [ __ ] me up at first my
uber took me to the wrong location at
first so I got out the I got out the car
it's [ __ ] snowing right by the way it
was negative 15 in Iowa that's what I'm
saying I he likes to test his luck
that's [ __ ] insane negative 15
degrees so I get out the / I'm in front
of the wrong house I'm in a neighborhood
empty ass neighborhood it's snowing
right I'm looking like I'm looking like
y'all what's good man just was good I'm
texting him he's any face times me he's
like yo the homies are coming out to get
you and I'm like I'm looking around I'm
like see a black van pull up [ __ ] I'm
looking like oh man they don't left me
outside to freeze it's no evidence with
this crime you know that [ __ ] that
ending state in training day where he's
just standing out there in the middle
everybody just coming out the
neighborhood yeah that could have been
dude in Des Moines in Des Moines Iowa so
then III called a I call the uber to the
correct destination cuz I guess I had
the address wrong at first and then it
was cooler than they were outside
chillin when I went inside I just drank
a bunch of Hennessy with him and his
peoples and got drunk and went back to
hotel this will woke up with his pants
off and his dick out of his bed just so
what
why did you dick Albert don't worry
about all that dawg
for the record I did not wake up with my
dear this guy has lost his [ __ ] mind
dude anybody that gets invited by an
Asian man that drops the n-word as
frequently as that man does and somebody
goes yo you don't have the right to say
that and he goes and what you gonna do
about it and they're like pretty much
nothing yeah that's that's a man that
I'm not trying to meet by the way mr.
stupid young if you would like to meet
me I would like to say hello is what out
this Nubia yeah man you know what he's
kind of he kind of really is blowing up
though man and I didn't expect that
because I actually saw him for the first
time there was like this YouTube channel
that that interviews a bunch of
gangbangers out in LA I don't know
jumper is yeah I think it's no jumper
yeah he was he was on it and this was
before he blew up
this kids [ __ ] crazy so we had we had
that exchange before the the no jumper
video oh [ __ ] and um and I remember
during our conversation he was telling
me cuz I was saying I was like I was and
I when I was explaining to him just my
words in that documentary I was just
saying I was like not a dog I'm just
saying like it's gonna be really
difficult for for Asians to to pop off
um talking that real gangster [ __ ] you
know and he was like well he was like
well just wait because I got co-signs by
this person that person I got this going
on I was like ma'am I'm rooting for you
I want I want you to pop off like you
like still mad at you what you trying to
say no I mean kind of he's just gotta be
like well look I mean you saying this
but I got this going on I was like well
that look good brought like I hope it
works out in it and it did you don't say
he was right like this shit's poppin for
him right now he was on a track with
this dude named Ozzy he's like he's like
a dude that blew up from Sacramento and
mas he's like a thug to and then he got
co-signed by like Kendrick and [ __ ] J
Cole as I was surprised that when he was
on a track Mazzio's like yo this dude
saw some next-level [ __ ] mm-hmm he
definitely has like that gangsta rap
[ __ ] yeah he's rapping about [ __ ] that
most people can't rap about because they
haven't done it I mean yeah yeah he just
he's tatted up all over the [ __ ]
place he was like a at your sketch dude
that's hairy man [ __ ] that he got Prison
tattoos don't [ __ ] somebody like that
oh nice your Hamill tattoos hell no dude
I can't do a tattoo I'm too indecisive
no I feel that I feel like if I get a
tattoo once I get it I'm a dislike it or
I'm gonna try to get another one and I'm
just end up sleeved the [ __ ] up man
that's funny is because when I was
younger I really wanted tattoos right
like I knew what I wanted I wanted like
I had specific images I wanted I knew
where I wanted them and all that [ __ ]
yeah and like I wanted a whole ass leave
I even wanted like a neck tattoo right
cuz I knew I could see with the neck
right because I would look so cool I
would just look like a sushi chef dude
it's just like a piece of sashimi on my
neck what some [ __ ] Oni and also
here's the thing too I always thought I
could because I used to have really bad
like cystic acne on my jawline so I
thought how easy would it be to just
cover that [ __ ] up with tattoos you know
I wouldn't worry about having clear skin
I'll just get tatted right here yeah
I've seen people do that but then um
also I got the mic covering my face
right now cuz this facial lady went in
on my skin bro pop and cut the [ __ ] out
of my like made little like
coquí's and squeeze a bunch of right not
important but look how smooth your skin
is though now tomorrow is gonna be
beautiful no so anyways but then when I
realized that I really really wanted to
act and I knew I could play really young
I thought let me just keep everything
looking as pure as possible right and
people will say yeah but they can cover
you with makeup but in my head I
imagined it cuz you know there's not a
lot of roles for Asian guys right yeah
and in my head I was like what if it
comes down to me and the guy without the
tattoos and they're like we got to spend
so much time covering Tim's tattoos like
I'm gonna keep it real pure you know
Dante Basco and you just going for the
same role what's funny is out when I was
younger I would watch like take the lead
right and where Dante Basco was he was
30 playing a high school kid I remember
thinking and that was one of my main
thoughts I was like if he started
playing high school kids it's like for
sure I can play high school kids for so
long right so let me keep everything
looking mad just young and clean I mean
he does the voiceover for a [ __ ]
11-year old for crying out loud he's
like 50 yeah bro [ __ ] egg from
Airbender or some [ __ ] he does the voice
for that kid last airbender I think
they're all like 15 16 yeah that's what
I'm saying like how can a [ __ ] 5th
year old man do the voice of a [ __ ]
12 year old well I mean animations weird
too you know because I remember when I
watched Chicken Little
that was a Zach Braff that's the voice
of like a little baby chicken you know I
don't even know that [ __ ]
yeah Brown yo you know what people have
been asking though this is a topic that
I thought would be great with you just
because um I used to get this [ __ ] a lot
specifically because I have a lot of
friendly relationships with a lot of my
with my girlfriend's right mhm
and I know for you like in your sketches
every time you have a sketch with number
one a female that's half naked or you
guys are kissing in a scene they go how
could you do that to Chia and aren't you
supposed to be in a committed
relationship and you consistently get
flack about that awesome yeah so like
for example when I would put up videos
or whatever and it would be me like
talking to geo TIFF or whatever we've
been friends now for like ten years
mm-hmm and they go oh well you should
you shouldn't probably hug him like that
and hug like hug like what like you
don't hug people you [ __ ] lonely
hardly hugging I don't know but then
people would say people it was such a
weird concept that peep
don't understand it'll work and I'm
talking about it would be from females
and guys so females would be like well
if I if my man was hugging up on another
girl like that I wouldn't be having that
[ __ ] and I'm like hold on a second you
insecure [ __ ] [ __ ] so insecure
that's such an odd thing for me like I
never understood that [ __ ] especially
because you you know people understand
your content right right right they see
that stuff they're like okay well how
would she feel about mm-hmm well that's
the thing because what people don't
realize is that um
first of all me and she had got together
when I was you know already kind of as
she was getting to know me she was
seeing my content understood the type of
stuff I did and you know when we weren't
officially official yet she would see
this stuff you know she would see me
going on tour and hanging out you know
with like import models cuz I would have
like shows at the import shows and [ __ ]
like that
so she understood that this is kind of a
part of my career and one what I do and
what I did right and so when I would do
these like suggestive skits with these
girls or whatever she always understood
that this was just a part of my career
and my sense of humor you know saying
it's my brand and the thing about it is
here's the thing about Jia is um she's
the [ __ ] like she's so dope she's such a
secure person yeah and not only she's
secure but she also like just like is
unbothered you feel me yeah and in her
head she always feels like if I'm dumb
enough to do something disrespectful
then vice will just leave you know and I
and and and also it's like why would I
do anything that she would hate and then
put it on line on a [ __ ] video
exactly even like when I when I say
jokes on Twitter people would tag her in
it like she doesn't have a Twitter or
like she can't just go on Twitter and
read it you know I'm saying and here's
the thing like they don't understand I
mean the the og fans realize now because
I've said it countless times but of
course there's always new subscribers
and followers that always want to you
know maybe I got a bunch of followers
from like the wedding video that was
trending right so they see me just as a
married person yeah and then all of a
sudden when I post a skit with like a
scantily clad flu
they're like there can lose you woman
yeah they're like how does your wife
feel about this and they haven't seen
the videos where we we specifically
explained look I don't do [ __ ] without
Shias approval first
I run everything by her even with the
recent I put up a little Fox IANA oh
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] flames thank you
bro thank I should [ __ ] play and
literally I was like hey babe I think I
want to get like a I think I might have
like a like my asian stripper homegirl
come to work in the video and she was
like okay and I was like well and and
like don't trip she's not gonna be
twerking on me she's like alright and
then she made a joke in the vlog she's
like whenever Tim does stuff like this I
make him pay a fee but you know it
that's basically all it is as long as I
communicate it with her she's fine
because she doesn't want to be surprised
the last thing she wants is to not know
about something then hear from somebody
and hears from somebody else and that's
the main thing and the only time she's
ever been had said something that made
me like okay I'm gonna take this video
down and re-edit it was in a vlog
because for her the skits right that's
me portraying a character like yeah
that's me but it still it's acting you
know saying like it's it's me writing a
script portraying a character and
putting on like a scene right yeah but
when it's a vlog that's me being me so
there was one time in a vlog where I was
gonna I was rapping on a homegirls track
and she was like yeah and I was like
yeah you know she asked me to hop on
this track and I was like if you hop on
this date nice plant I saw that she's
like hey you know what that joke she's
like I didn't like that joke oh god yeah
yeah yeah babe
immediately private of the video took it
down re-edit it took out that joke and
then re-upload it yeah and it's all
about communication too and what I'm
finding out too with a lot of these like
girls or guys whoever it is people like
to put whatever they went through in
their past with their [ __ ] up
relationships on to you and they go well
that's not how I would deal well that's
why you're not with me you dumb [ __ ]
yeah alright that's why you're sitting
over there you're trying to control the
person that you're with and you know
what if the person that you're with is
okay with that that's fine but for you
to go out of your way to come onto
somebody else's space to tell somebody
how to conduct how
they are with the person that they love
when that person's okay with it it's
very odd to me it's like well I don't
think I would be okay with it well
that's cool I'm not with you you [ __ ]
[ __ ] back so why the [ __ ] do you care
what are you talking about
that's the thing - it's so silly because
like you know even like with the with
the with the girl twerking in the video
right yeah she doesn't I don't touch her
once like I don't even touch her like
hand you know she's just working around
me yeah and there were comments that
were like if this was my man he wouldn't
be my man anymore I'm like for a little
for being around a but yeah you don't
say [ __ ] are you talking to me like he's
I'm not even touch it i nev n' I didn't
even really look at the cakes yeah
they were just around me I'm like what
kind of relationships do y'all have that
you know you're so paranoid about each
other you how ugly are you how [ __ ]
ugly are you and this is coming from an
ugly man how hideous are you to the
point where any woman that's around the
person that you're with that you have to
feel so insecure bro you can't make that
joke anymore you are cute now let me
tell you every time every time I post
the same foods Oh David looking good
that's when I do my hair I wash my face
and I wear some clothes I'll tell you
this though it's funny because like I
like fashion I like clothes but there's
just huge lazy comedian side of me and
it's because you know when I was when I
started doing YouTube a lot of people
didn't know this and I might have
mentioned this on this podcast but I
specifically I specifically more free
shirts anything any shirt that I got for
free I wore it on a vlog okay
it was like an inside joke that I was
doing that I just didn't tell people it
was kind of like I was trolling myself
almost so I still wear like so my friend
went to Rwanda for but he got me this
freedom or wanded tori shirt I wore that
okay I got his fleamarket shirt that I
just grabbed from my aunt I want that
[ __ ] and I was just trying to look as
trashy as possible because prior to
doing comedy I did music and I felt like
with music you had to dress a certain
way nag there's certain way and be
something in order to be popular on that
space right and this is way before
[ __ ] SoundCloud and everything else
where you had like you know private
distribution or whatever I right right
so for me I felt that pressure so much I
wanted to do the opposite now not to say
that my regular dress was any better
than what I was wearing on the vlogs but
I just specifically wanted to dress
as trashy as possible because I was
trying to make a point that you don't
have to look a certain way to be funny
in comedy yeah I don't have to right it
doesn't make sense so if anything else
if you look weirder the better that it
is I mean that's the beauty of being a
comedian right it's kind of like um
almost I almost feel like the the
funnier looking comedians are the
funnier ones you know it's like when you
see a really attractive stand-up
comedian you're like well get outta here
you know who's actually pretty funny
though your boy Matt right I was just
gonna bring up Matt right so Matt ryf is
a sexy ass dude especially now he's been
boxing and working out he's like buff
his [ __ ] now yeah but even before he got
buff he just had a cute face yeah and so
it's like he gets onstage
thank God he fixed his teeth though no I
saw his previous teeth that [ __ ] look
crazy yeah they were they were tiny that
[ __ ] look like the soundboard on this
wall dude but he's [ __ ] funny he's a
funny dude and he used to UM the during
his set he would play he would play to
that he would get on stage and be like I
know what you're thinking I look like
one of those vine douchebags yeah I
swear you know and he would go into this
whole thing about like how he looks like
a Backstreet Boy but he's a funny guy
you know but that's just like I mean
like we're saying when when you see a
traditionally attractive stand-up
immediately you're kind of like he's not
that funny right what does he know what
has he been through yeah [ __ ] with your
cute privilege I know you're white and
you're cute get the [ __ ] out of here
he's yeah but I was a I watched his
stand because you mentioned to me he was
funny and I saw it when he was super
young obviously he was young so it
wasn't that good he had no life
experience the same [ __ ] with me but I
saw one recently and this like number
one like his set is super like
thought-out
mm-hmm very comfortable on stage and man
I like that fool is gonna be good man
yeah he gives a [ __ ] about his craft
yeah you know a lot of people might
sleep on it because of the way he looks
but that boys working dude and he has
talent he's definitely working you know
and he has a very good way of being like
not trying too hard you know it's like a
very chill but good but doesn't take
himself too seriously you know you know
what that fool he went out with who
what's her face it was all over the
Internet what is her name Kate
Beckinsale Kate bacon you [ __ ] cute
son of a [ __ ] yeah when I saw that [ __ ]
I hated him I was like how did Kate well
actually I know he's a very good-looking
man he was he was you know what that he
was pissed that that happened too
because like once the paparazzi kind of
guy
wind of that yeah it kind of [ __ ] up I
mean I think I think it [ __ ] things up
for them just because like you know I
think whenever you're in something new
when you're testing out the waters and
then straight fragile yeah and then I
think everyone's putting it on blast and
they're like who is this guy and you
know and there was an age difference
when people were talking [ __ ] I think
that kind of you know put a little let's
put some waves in their in their in
their ride
you know I don't even know how that
happens how did he even get to meet her
meet her like what I'm pretty sure she
just came to one of his um was randomly
at like I don't know the Improv or
something when he was doing a set that
was mad she were just like hey you're a
cutie pie he makes me want to work out
dude I'm he makes me want to work out
also like dude it's like you can be
funny and Buffy told me that she ro
don't let me get clear skin amber I will
start I will I will start no I'm married
yeah I used to tweet the [ __ ] out I was
like yo God made me fat because it'd be
unfair for other dudes out there that's
so funny dog cuz I say same [ __ ] I used
to say God gave me Agni to keep me
humble yeah cuz I'm like yo I'm already
like cocky and cuz I don't give me clear
skin bro I will be annoying as [ __ ] you
know it's interesting because you know
when people first meet you they the the
the first thing they notice is your
level of confidence right and there's a
difference between being confident and
cocky
there's this there's this type of what
the word it's like energy or vibe that
you get from somebody right and it's
your thing is just I Know Who I am and
I'm very comfortable with it right and a
lot of the times when I meet people on
the space people have the opposite of
that which is i'ma meet somebody and I'm
gonna try to be something that I'm not
exactly and it was it was hard for me
when I first moved to LA because there
was only a handful of people that I met
were just being authentically them
mm-hmm and every time I met somebody who
was in new media whether it's and I from
what I'm gathering from my anecdotal
evidence is that people expect you to be
a certain way because do you think that
when you come to this city in LA you
have to be that type of persona and it
is the most obnoxious thing that I had
to deal with it's because well who told
you you had to be something be somebody
else to come into the city hmm and when
I would meet these people I just I don't
like people when they're not themselves
so you could be an [ __ ] you could be
a nice person whatever that you are
at least when I meet you I need to be
able to understand who you are as a
person right
so it just stresses me out if I don't
man and that's what gives people the
impression that la is fake too because
you have all these people coming from
everywhere trying to pursue something
that they see on like Keeping Up with
the Kardashians right so they feel like
they need to be at these events and they
need to be on their Hollywood [ __ ]
because they feel like they're at some
Hollywood [ __ ] and then you have all
these people right not from LA yeah
trying to be what they think is la
talking to other people not from LA so
then they're absolutely they leave this
[ __ ] like wow la is fake is [ __ ]
everybody so like pretentious and trying
to be something they're not but there's
like no man that's y'all like people
that from LA aren't like that you know
and it's like you kind of have to know
how to play the game you know as and and
people will say that sounds fake but
there's a difference between going to an
event like that and building
relationships and networking right yeah
and like I would never go to an event
like that trying to be best friends with
somebody like what you know I'm saying
that's not what we're here for that's
not what you're here for
yeah so don't come out here pretending
like oh you couldn't find true friends
and [ __ ] like you didn't come here to
make friends you came out here to pursue
something you saw on Instagram yeah and
then you're bitter now because no one
wants to help you when you ain't doing
[ __ ]
yeah you know and that's that's do that
straight of facts because your purpose
and like you said your purpose wasn't to
make friends so now you're upset that
you don't have friends when the wait
when the only reason why you were
connecting with people was simply just
to get a leg up in whatever you know
entertainment thing that you're doing
right now yeah so what are you expecting
out of these relationships absolutely
nothing and I started to find out too
for me specifically that there was a lot
of people here that cuz for me I like to
like somebody first before I work with
them it's just same it's just you know
what's the point and you know I like you
have to be at least agreeable with me so
what I found out with a lot of people
this was my fault
is that I would confuse a likeable
person with a good person mm-hmm so some
people are just very good at putting it
on right and then they kind of just use
you up for what you're worth and when
you ask them for a favor back they just
disappear mm-hm and that was the the the
harsh reality that I got I'm like no
well I'm [ __ ] up
now because I'm developing relationship
with people that just because they're
nice to me hmm
they weren't nice to me because they
were good people they weren't nice to me
because they wanted something out of em
and I always looked at them now like
they're trash because first of all
you're trying to [ __ ] get something
I'm a seedless celebrity how low are you
in the totem pole did the [ __ ] are you
thinking about and so like for example
there was a dude that you know we're
cordial now mm-hmm
but the guy his mission in life was to
do entertainment in music okay and you
know he's a talented dude but when we
were working together like I was doing
this music project and he was supposed
to mix it and he was supposed to do all
the stuff for and mind you it was like
an acoustic thing so it's literally one
vocal chain one guitar thing that's it
right and it's been like a couple months
it didn't do anything it was one song
and I was like what's going on and then
he started hanging out with other people
that were a little more mainstream media
and he just bounced out and disappeared
and I got so [ __ ] upset at him I was
so pissed just because he was dodging my
calls and mind you we kicked it a lot
right out of nowhere he just started
dodging my [ __ ] yeah and by the way this
project was paid I paid him for this tow
you paid him sedate him so I paid him
and I was like okay cool so I was like
hey you come to my house right now in
the next hour I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
it got to that point cuz he stole my
money now right he stole my money I know
where he lives
yeah yeah I mean I've helped him out
when he moved to the city so you come to
this place where I'm a [ __ ] you up it
was just that to that point dodging my
calls took my money just disappeared
right right and mind you it's not like
I'm a fight or anything but somebody
steals my money and at this time I was
broke oh this is before a fighter Dave
this is before fighter days I'm just
gonna have to take the chance I'm a
[ __ ] but he's a bigger [ __ ] than me so
I'm at the calls Bluff
so he comes over and I just kind of go
off on him I'm like I don't give a [ __ ]
about anything else I was like
friendship is friendship business is
business but you [ __ ] up on both ends
Yeah right so you can't just up and
disappear off of me just because you
found somebody else that can help you
out better with your music or some [ __ ]
this was a pay project right [ __ ] all
that other [ __ ] and then we didn't talk
for like five or six years but he
apologized later
did he ever give you the song no I just
took him to has somebody else makes it
God cuz it was just I didn't want to
work with him like yeah burn that bridge
that's wack so you know and he's one of
those people that moved here and then
every time he's around somebody he's a
likable human being hmm so he's likable
but he would drop you in a second if
there's somebody else that's above you
that
could gain something off and that's the
thing right that'll only get you so far
because then you start to kind of gain a
reputation as somebody who does that
right because and and I look I try to be
nice to everybody because in my in the
back of my mind I'm gonna be a [ __ ]
to somebody or blow somebody off and
then it's like in The Incredibles when
when he tells buddy to like to go away
when buddy's trying to be like his his
like super fan and [ __ ] you seen the
incredible yeah and then buddy comes
back as the super villain and I'm like I
don't or even in an Iron Man you know
I'm saying when he dismisses some dude
and that guy makes it his whole like
ammo to just destroy Iron Man I'm like
and in my head I'm like let me not be an
[ __ ] because some guys gonna make it
his [ __ ] goal in life to destroy my
career or some [ __ ] you know so I try to
be nice to everybody I try not to burn
bridges cuz also you never know when
someone might like you know need someone
for a project or whatever maybe someone
else has something poppin and they think
of you you know so I just try to be
nicer I heard a lot of stories like that
about comics mmm so you know when um I
can't say names because it's not my
story to tell but yeah like certain
comics would when they're doing really
well you would expect them if they were
a part of the same clique to just kind
of bring each other up as a part of a
crew right but certain comics would blow
up and they would just ignore all these
other people or they would bash them and
they would just tell them like certain
like straight-up like oh you're not
gonna make it you're not good enough for
this space and then specifically this
comic that told me this it was a male
comic that was safe to female comics mmm
like you're never gonna be good enough
well guess what that comic is not
booking anything and the female comics
that that that he was talking [ __ ] to
they all blew up real ie Ali Wong ah
like Chelsea Handler okay [ __ ] like that
so it's it's kind of crazy dude like or
was he Jedi mind trick them and
motivating them by talking [ __ ] maybe
but I guarantee you he wasn't he was
basically saying that female comics
aren't funny uh and now these people are
big right and now these women are
actually helping the other people who
supported them during this time like
there was a stigma that female comics
just weren't funny they were funny as
male comics and mind you for me I didn't
find female comics as funny not because
they were females is because I just
couldn't relate to them right you know
that's that's all I mean there's also
like there's like that was all
like uh before means were means that was
almost like a like a like a joke yeah
and like oh girls aren't funny yeah I'm
saying but then like that's silly cuz
you know I loved Lucy's like one of my
favorite shows of all time so oh yeah I
Love Lucy dude all those classics super
funny dude and Ali Wong - when I saw her
special dude [ __ ] funny and I said
look I grew up I mean especially as an
Asian boy
I remember you know back when Comedy
Central used to only show just stand up
all the time yeah I used to watch all
the time and Margaret's show I was like
she had the stand-up special that I used
to watch like every week dude it just
cracked me up and I like as like a young
asian watching I'd be like man this is
this is this is dope to see an Asian on
TV doing stand-up and she was a lady
yeah and you know what with with
Margaret Cho - she she kind of had that
first wave in that movie what I found
out was she was just that asian girl
that just didn't give a [ __ ] she would
say whatever the [ __ ] she wanted and for
a lot of like young Asian kids that
thought that they you know they they
were supposed to be the doctor the
businessperson and kind of reserved
their comments they kind of used her as
fuel to speak up about certain things
right especially because she's number
one a female comic coming has bunch of
tattoos talks about sex [ __ ] whatever
and she's a lesbian yeah which is
[ __ ] crazy but I think she's bisexual
I'm not sure something like that I don't
know her sexual [ __ ] is crazy that she's
like she's all out that she's definitely
not in the whole like monogamy right
you know heterosexual Lane but she was
just open about everything which is kind
of crazy man I mean I feel like you know
that's kind of what what what she did is
kind of what helps you and me yeah kind
of blow up in the space that we did
because you know in the early stages of
YouTube right I feel like one of the
things that helped me gain my audience
was the fact that a lot of people Asian
and not Asian were seeing me like
dressed the way I dress and not only
talk the way I talk but also talk about
the things I talked about like I'd be
talking about my dick all the time I'd
be talking sexual things and there was
half the people who were Asian kids who
were like wow finally not a like cookie
cutter stereotype Asian someone I can
watch someone I can relate to but also
people that weren't Asian who didn't
grow up around Asian people were like oh
my god I've never seen an Asian guy
talking like this yeah this is kind of
weird yeah right people were like thrown
off by me
just being the way I am yeah you know
I'm sayin and that's what kind of really
helped me in the beginning like garner
and audience it's such a weird thing too
because I think we grew up in an area
where it is so culturally diverse mm-hmm
we think that the world that we live in
is a representation of everywhere else
in America and it's not right and so I
was shot like I didn't understand why
people were like oh look at this dude
and first of all by the way me of all
people like I have a slight twing to my
voice but for a majority of my life I
try to get rid of it because I couldn't
get a job mmm right so when I would
speak at these jobs and I you know grow
up into Sacramento California everybody
kind of speaks a certain way right right
so for me I got rid of most of it but
even then when when I would hear myself
speak I didn't hear what they were
hearing like oh why are you trying to
sound black like what the [ __ ] are you
talking my talketh why does [ __ ] in my
head you know because in in my group of
friends that I grew up around with I did
speak white as [ __ ] as they would say
mm-hmm so to other people who didn't
grow up in that area with that little
thing that they're hearing they think
that I'm trying to sound quote-unquote
black that's what I'm saying like and
that's what's crazy because you know yes
we grew up in very diverse areas right
so everybody in the school I went to
like we all like dress the same and talk
the same and but it was like you know
black Asian Mexican it was like a white
dude couple white dudes and we all just
coming you know listen say music talk
about the same stuff and and so when I
started making YouTube videos yeah it's
like and don't mind you you know I'm not
a gangster I never claimed to be a
gangster right sure I mean um I mean I'm
a G yeah you don't say but I know
gangster right and so I would definitely
be in videos and people would be like
who's this wannabe gangster because like
I would have like a backwards hat on
that's so funny you know or you know
maybe I had a you know I'm saying with
slip you know yeah and I'm like brah
where are you from like what what what
[ __ ] suburb of Wisconsin Oshkosh
Wisconsin are you in where an Asian guy
just wearing a backwards hat makes you
associate that would gangster [ __ ] yeah
silly bro everything was oh you're
trying to be a thug oh you think you're
so G like oh you think you're ready to
throw down what are you talking about
who said who said this [ __ ] and it's
funny too cuz I would read up for
example to like growing up in this or
neighborhood
that I had everybody got into fistfights
mm-hm and so when I would tell these
stories about me getting the fights
they're like oh you think you [ __ ]
tell you that you could throw down no
I'm telling you I got bullied I'll tell
you people are bullying me I'm not
saying like they're like oh you beat
yeah I beat this guy up because he was
trying to kick my ass and I'm a big guy
I didn't know that either I'm like six
foot one 200 and [ __ ] ten pounds yeah
you know and so what would happen is
like a lot of the situations that I got
into was just because of the
neighborhood that I grew up in whether
you were a geek or nerd or whatever
everybody got in the [ __ ] fights
that's just how it was somebody was
trying to rob you somebody was trying to
take your [ __ ] right it's just you know
and I think like when people would hear
those stories they're like oh you think
you're a thug bully do supposed to do
you know what he's like so I grew up in
an area that no and no one was trying to
no one was really get into fights yeah
is we're all cool
I just chilling you know even when I
because I went to I went to a Christian
school from in gardena from like
preschool to eighth grade basically and
when I started going to public school
and paramount was my first kind of like
literally my first day at paramount mind
you this is my first time at a public
school ever right yeah
and so I'm chillin paramount was like I
think like 75% Mexican paramount high
yeah like 20 percent black and the rest
is like little spurts of like Pacific
Islander and Asian and white yeah so I'm
in there it's my first disco I'm in the
bathroom peeing in stall literally dog
as I start peeing with my dick in my
hand
three-three cholo looking Mexican do is
walk in two of them look at the one
doing they're like you ready go
they start jumping him into their gang
in the bath - your pee as I'm peeing dog
as my dick is in my hand there's do
cholos jumping another would be cholo
into the gang and I'm like oh my god I
just couldn't I was like so I like I
didn't want it so here's what was going
on in my mind I didn't want to just put
my dick away and walk out cuz I'm like
ah they're gonna think I'm like nervous
or scared so I stood there with my dick
in my hand waited because I couldn't pee
I was too nervous hey my dick in my hand
pretended like I peed pretending to
shake it off and then walked out even
though they give a [ __ ] what's going on
but she didn't know you could actually
cut off a stream so quick
people say you can't [ __ ] cut off
your piss stream when you're scared you
can make it happen
yeah definitely that's crazy but that's
my first day at Paramount and then like
walking a fool you [ __ ] you're ready
ballot hey I respect you I respect you
okay what's going on but you know and
but then like that's really probably the
closest I've ever you know I mean yeah
there were fights at Paramount but no no
one gave me no problems you know cuz I I
actually got to I was popular you
probably just a guy that could float
into any group and everybody who you
were yeah yeah I also used to bootleg
CDs for that helped okay so here the
connecting [ __ ] yeah nobody go jump that
connect exactly sophomore year hours um
sophomore year because here's the thing
mind you this is my first time being in
public school so I this is my first time
I'm dressing like like trying to dress
cool you know I'm saying cuz oh because
you had a uniform it was uniforms in
junior high and an a in elementary
school so this is my first time like
being like oh I got a dress cool yeah
but I also didn't wanna you know because
my parents were you know like the
restaurant was doing okay but we you
know pretty like broke you know I didn't
want to bother my parents with this
mainstream like Sean John and Air Force
love it echo echo echo unlimited slap oh
yeah bro so I'm like I got to find a way
to make money so I'll go to smart and
final sophomore year I went smart and
final you know I would buy just boxes of
Snickers and M&Ms in bulk and I would
take them in Ziploc bags and sell them
at school for like a dollar each and
that's how I made like my extra clothes
money and then a funny story a one time
specifically I was in class and my
English teacher mr. Wolfe I was like I
was in the middle of a transaction and
he was like Tim you selling candy in my
class what program is is for and I was
super cool my drama teacher yeah mr.
Carlin is like drama class he was like
oh I'm sure mr. Carlin would love to
hear that you're selling candy in the
middle my class give me the bag so he
takes my bag I'm like [ __ ] so then right
after third period I ran to mr.
carlaandmike honor God okay
mr. Wolfe took my candy I told him I was
selling it for drama class he was like
all right so I had drama for fifth
period
I get the fifth period and Karlin hands
me a bag of money and he's like yeah I
has your bag kids kept wanting to buy
the candy
[Laughter]
that's like yo man here's a 10% cut yeah
thank you man
yo that's so interesting to some
teachers don't really get it either you
know they're so busy trying to look at
what you're doing wrong they don't see
the bigger picture well first of all I
get this kid selling candy he probably
isn't have a lot of money so what the
[ __ ] am i doing right you know what why
am i dude I remember to so dirty lunch I
used to play 13 in the [ __ ]
Vietnamese card game right have you ever
played that [ __ ] so we're playing 13 and
you know what lunch or whatever and I
[ __ ] I can't remember her name because
she wasn't one of my teachers but she
wasn't Ettore ously known for being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] gaping kunti [ __ ]
Oh God and so so he were like playing
cards and she goes you know you're not
supposed to play cards on campus like
we're gambling or some [ __ ] was like
we're not gambling we're just playing
thirteen she takes the deck of cards and
she just Chuck's it on the [ __ ] roof
oh god what a [ __ ]
you know the kunti gaping [ __ ] yeah and
I was so shocked she goes I don't ever
want to see you playing cards here again
like that I was like yo what in the [ __ ]
and after she left I was I got another
deck right here we started place you oh
you think you're so funny and she'd try
to grab a nose I know I'm not you're not
doing that [ __ ] and the bell ring I just
walked away but that same [ __ ] day I
had a Japanese teacher her name is sato
sensei chateaux sensei that's all times
day so sad that sensei was gonna teach
us how to make this thing called oh yeah
code on its eggs and chicken it's like
chicken in a [ __ ] so in the teacher call
it the what came first the chicken or
the egg and so we were she was making
oyakodon in the teachers noun in between
the language classes and so that's where
the spanish teacher the japanese teacher
in the german teacher show their [ __ ] so
she's making food and I just hear people
yelling and then we're in class and then
I walk outside and it was the [ __ ] then
looking through my deck of cards Inge
upon the roof and then Sato sensei was
battling her out what like straight up
she was just like first of all it's not
those hens they doesn't speak very good
English at all and she was like telling
her like well you know this whole area
isn't just for you as she was cooking
the food for the class right it's just
that you don't speak to me that way
throwdown I was just outside we were all
cheering her on as she was [ __ ] going
at this lady and then when she came in
we just gave her a [ __ ] round of
applause I felt that she defended my
honor for the cut the deck of cards dude
[ __ ] [ __ ] a [ __ ] as you came back
she comes back with the other teachers
dead body and you because for you she
had her [ __ ] head like this from a
samurai sword
the dagger cards in the mouth of the of
the butt of the head one of my favorite
teachers actually this lady named
Michigan Mitsu she was Japanese my
history teacher in high school and she
she left me with something to this day
that I think back on mm-hmm and it was
in my yearbook and you know everyone
sign my yearbook so I was passing it
around to my class and then uh and she
wrote and it was really simple but
really like advices stuck with me you
know and she wrote Tim you know she's
like you're so talented and and you're
such a funny guy but remember that like
no matter how talented you are it won't
get you anywhere unless you focus and
put in the work and I was like I was
like okay okay and I was like yeah she's
right because you know I was a notorious
like you know I was a class clown I was
voted class clown and [ __ ] you know and
there were multiple teachers that gave
me the whole Tim that speech was like
there's no reason why a talented brain
like yours should be getting like a see
my class yeah I'm saying like my honors
English teacher told me that and then I
had a an algebra teacher specifically
who was like pissed at me because I
think I I didn't pass algebra the first
time or algebra two or some [ __ ] like
that yeah I think I needed to graduate
so they they did this thing where they
separated half of the semester into two
semesters so it was just like easier
yeah and this one teacher specifically
he was like Tim you do this
every time you start off so great and
then you start slacking off so they used
to get more pissed at me because I was
smart and I was I was always goofing off
because it's frustrating cuz they see
something great in somebody yeah and you
know other people who can't understand
the material is just because they're
dumb as [ __ ] okay or you know what
whatever the reason is but they see
somebody who understands and then you go
like [ __ ] it I can really do with that
[ __ ] I get why that was frustrating for
them you know so when Michigan minsu
told me that my yearbook
like okay and to this day I'm like I'm
like okay man
stop goofing around putting work never
said that [ __ ] to me dude
they always said wow I'm surprised
you're going to college I I kid you
[ __ ] not so when my senior of high
school I decided to join a choir yeah
just because I didn't want to join quiet
cuz I don't want to get made fun of
right you know whatever the homies or
whatever will call me like a [ __ ]
loser yeah you know and when you're
young you you're impressionable you know
I wasn't as impressionable as other
people just because I did like you know
till this day I just never gave a [ __ ]
but it's - David door Amy so David fatso
son of a [ __ ] I told her so back in the
day when I was a kid I was like chubby
still chubby till this day but when I
started getting fat around third or
fourth grade [ __ ] these kids call me
David fat so and then I had nothing to
say because it was so good I think one
day anybody make fun of your name and I
was like yep David fatso and I cracked I
died he died and I told him the other
one which is David so fat it's so simple
but so great dude what was your dick it
was nothing uh alright so you know my
birth name is tim chantarangsu it's my
legal name so kids would be like Tim you
know first was like Tim Chattanooga Tim
chimichanga Tim Tim chant the wrong song
and he was trying to relate to me how
are you Chad the wrong song is nothing
dude that's hurtful for someone like me
who really like to learn songs my [ __ ]
was too factual because the evidence was
there to fat shoe your bigger kid was
[ __ ] hard though I do bar told me
that when he was a little kid anything
hurt his feelings like they used to call
him bartender anyone make him cry say
alright bartender he goes I'm not a
bartender as it was a bartender I don't
know honey would hurt my [ __ ] shoe
he's like okay then cute guy yo so when
I wasn't a choir we had to do this thing
well basically we would perform to the
elementary schools in the area and so
there was a lady named Miss Richardson
that was my kindergarten teacher that
remembered me and I was always a
troublesome kid I used to get in fights
all the [ __ ] time specifically I came
here
I'm an immigrant so when I came here I
just get bullied a lot mm-hmm right and
so but my dad would always tell me being
the cream man that he is he goes don't
you ever get into fights in school but
how old were you I was I came here I was
like three or four okay like then okay
and then he told me don't ever get into
fights but being the angry Korean man
that he is if they put their hands on
you you can just do whatever you want
right right and so I would always wait
for somebody just touch me anything just
so I wouldn't get in trouble my parents
cuz didn't matter if I got beat up in
school I'd get my ass beat at home MA so
I just had to wait for them to just put
their hands on me or anything like just
push me touch me anything so ask you
this so my classic saying and even my
teachers knew I would say that I'll be
able touch me see what happens
mmm Wow even as a little kid I would say
touch me see what happens and this is
probably a phrase I picked up from some
of the older people the neighborhood
right but I would just wait for them to
push me mess with my hair so just like
it just starts swinging so that's what I
was known for and so um because I got
bullied a lot because I look like a
[ __ ] weirdo when I got bully 2 was
well deserved I I did the choir
performance for the elementary school
and a coach Gator and I remember cuz
miss Richardson remember me because I
used to get into so many [ __ ] fights
and it sucked because she understood
that I used to get bullied a lot and I
just wouldn't take it
it didn't matter I would just start
swinging on people yeah like she
remembered the first time I got into a
fight and I remember this too cuz it
stuck out in my head cuz we were playing
house mm-hmm
and you know playing house we're cooking
[ __ ] and I was cooking with this pot and
this kid trying to take it from me so I
snatched it and I [ __ ] smashed him on
the face with it oh my gosh remember
that [ __ ] and she goes well how are you
you're in choir you sing now I was like
yeah well I'm going to the University of
California Riverside and this [ __ ] got
me she goes you're going to college bro
that [ __ ] broke my heart
what did you think of me like she she
probably thought I was trash as a five
year old dumbass hooligan yeah like how
bad was I do like how [ __ ] terrible
was because in third grade I got removed
from that school cuz I stabbed the kid
in the face lord have mercy
yeah so like what I mean I told this on
JK news but long story short there's a
kid his name was Del Rey more guys super
nice now by the way yo you met her
recently yo so we reconnected after a
while so Del Rey was I don't know what
happened in his personal family life or
whatever and then that led him to be
such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but you know you know shoutouts to Dell
right now hopefully you're still a good
dude I don't know yeah but basically
during that time you know throwing
spitballs was really pop so uh I can't
remember this teachers name but she was
faced to the wall you know doing the
whiteboard [ __ ] and as she was doing
that or a chalkboard [ __ ] people were
throwing spitballs mm-hmm I wasn't
having that [ __ ] I was actually trying
to do my work putting a good little
Asian kid doing my work and this kid Del
Ray apparently got hit in the side of a
face with the spit ball and I say
apparently cuz I saw it and I started
busting up laughing it was so [ __ ]
funny cuz that [ __ ] was juicy blah and
then he saw me laugh
he thought I did it to him ah so I
started cracking the [ __ ] up and I went
back and I started doing my [ __ ] next
thing you know guy chucks me out of my
[ __ ] chair Oh God so I just see red
and then I remember this
I grab my pencil and I was because I was
writing I was grabbing and I just
started hammer facing this dude's face
Oh Mike what the pants ah yeah but I was
trying to punch him I wasn't trying to
like stab him yeah and I didn't know oh
good you know scratched up and he and I
actually put the pencil through his
cheek into the mouth all the way through
with the pencil oh my god yeah and so
the teacher turns around she's screaming
she's like oh my god I don't know what's
going on I just see this hole and blood
coming out and she has a paper towel
that she puts to his face you know that
recycled brown paper towel from that
ending that rolled out oh yeah she's
putting it to his face I don't know what
the [ __ ] is happening and then literally
she's screaming her head on because his
kid got stabbed in class you scary and
then the principal came up to me took me
on he goes what happened I don't know
and he goes I said I don't know I and I
said the dumbest excuse i goes by
pinched him and he clearly knows
something happened but as he started to
talk to me and he knows he knows about
me cuz i got bullied a lot in school and
he knows that at the time del rey was a
troublemaker hmm so he was like he kind
of put two and two together and he goes
you know he was probably getting bullied
and he had it right so i actually they
allowed me to stay in the school for a
little bit and really until they had to
figure out what to do until I had to get
removed from the school because it was
so bad because his older brother
actually beat me up in school because
because of that [ __ ] and then it got to
the point where I can't in you Lee had
fistfights at the school because I had
to defend myself because they just knew
me as a kid that stabbed somebody dance
so like I got removed from that school
because of that situation
now now that dude El Rey he actually hit
me up later on cuz the dude was working
at in and out and you know if you work
it in and out number one you have to be
a really good human being right and and
you're getting good money
exactly so I'm sitting it in and out is
dude Del Rio this is by the way after
this junior I he jumped me okay cuz he
still remembered the [ __ ] stabbing he
held it in with him yeah yeah and mind
you this dude was still pissed from it
six years well he had a disgusting scar
now now there was no scar he was fine
looks like a cute dimple now and so the
dude jumps me and I remember cuz I as a
kid I used to get my ass people my
parents I'm talking about sticks bets
whatever yeah and so I remember we're at
the bus stop you know what now whatever
he swings on me and I just took a hit to
the face and I looked at him it didn't
hurt and I was like so I just sorted
rushing after he runs into the bus and
goes all the way to the back and he just
starts talking all this other [ __ ] like
just and I'm just sitting there I'm like
just wait till we get off the bus that's
like I said it just wait till we get off
the bus yeah yeah and I just stood up
and I'm about to swing on him and the
[ __ ] bus driver heard me say all that
[ __ ] and then or you know whatever kids
were like telling on him all the way to
the front on me or some [ __ ] has he had
a lot of homies and then later I'm about
to swing on a bus driver grabs me off
and then do Big John he's waiting at the
bus stop cuz I guess like they just kind
of radioed in and they took me off he
took me to the office cuz I was gonna
swing on him and then I just wait I was
just wait till we get off the bus lo and
behold later on I see him in and out and
this is one where after high school and
he goes hey what's up David how you
doing man you know it's been a while
he's like cleaning my table and super
nice I'm like I thought he was gonna
beat me up or like jump me so I was
getting ready yeah the [ __ ] is dude
animal style
yeah animal style and he comes up and he
goes yo how you been and he apologized
yo I'm sorry about you know I was going
through like some hard [ __ ] at the time
you know I'm a different person now and
I just sat there and I felt terrible
right cuz I was thinking about smashing
my animal style fries into his face you
know what I've been Boss as a little kid
if you after you stabbed him with a
pencil uh-huh I mean like I hope you get
the point
and then walked off dude just like that
yeah it's Rob depends alone but all I
said was I pinched him stupid David the
dumbest excuse ever alright on that no I
gotta go well you guys that was a solid
almost hour that's like 58 minutes or so
was it yeah actually pretty good sweet
but anyways guys working it yo you got a
podcast - no it's called oh jeez oh yeah
I have a new podcast just launched
recently it's called No Chaser it's on
all the you know iTunes Spotify all that
all the streaming [ __ ] it's me my boy
Ricky shucks and and the lovely Nikki
blades check that out we mainly focus on
sex and relationships and stuff and
nothing about so tune in if you like
also watch our show send foods on
Thrillist and love you yeah man timothy
delaghetto everybody by sucking nut like
a dick
[Laughter]